So gentlemen, I, I
admire what you're doing
because you Miles,
for putting up with JB.
Oh yeah.
[Conan] And JB, you for
offering this unique power
that you have to mesmerize
people, slow them down.
(JB sighs)
[Conan] You're doing it
to me right now.
I'm speaking.
Oh yeah, you better slow down.
[Conan] More slowly.
Yeah, see, see you're more calm.
I'm ready to accept.
What I'm gonna give you.
Let me, look,
matter of fact, this, don't
even worry about the door.
Leave the window wide
open, just leave it open.
Leave the window open, okay?
It's cold out.
I know it's cold, I
know, I know it's chilly,
I know it's chilly.
See, see, see, see, now you're
thinking about the cold.
You're not thinking about
accepting what I'm giving you.
Okay. Okay.
So don't worry about,
metaphorically, leave the window open.
Yes, leave the window open, okay.
And, and if you were really
doing me a favor, just
like those old TV shows, you
would have a nice pie sitting
on that window sill to cool off.
(Matt laughs)
[JB] Do you understand?
You want a cooling pie on the window?
That's what they do, that's
what they do back in the day.
They bake, they bake a pie,
plum pie, peach pie,
and they put it on the window sill.
(Sona laughs)
You don't have to specify
which kind of pie.
Look, 'cause I, I see I'm, I'm saying it
because I got to activate your senses.
Every sense you have.
Yes.
[JB] One, your sight, your sense of smell.
Okay, this is good.
In cartoons,
you know, when they put a
pie on that window sill,
that smell of the pie
floats through the room.
Yes!
[JB] And then, have you
seen that on cartoons?
It flows.
Yes, I--
[JB] It travels through the rooms
and it goes under your,
under your nostrils.
And then you levitate,
and you float your ass to the pie.
(Sona laughs)
Okay. That's what I'm doing right now.
[JB] Levitating, and you float to the pie.
So if you just put,
here's what you've done.
I've left the window of my psyche open.
(hums) There you go.
[Conan] JB Smoove.
And, and as he requested, I
left the window open regardless
of the temperature outside.
And I left
a cooling peach pie.
(JB hums)
It's peach and it's got a
little rhubarb in there too.
Oh I love rhubarb, just, just, not a lot,
just a little bit.
Just a little bit, not too much.
[JB] Yep.
No, it's, it's, I want to say 80% peach.
The details, it's the details.
See that's what they think,
the, the, the details get me.
[Conan] Yeah.
Keep, keep, going and keep it going.
A little bit, a little bit
of cinnamon in there too.
(JB hums)
[Conan] A little bit of cinnamon in there
with the sugar.
(JB hums)
[Conan] And it's cooling.
It's hot, just out of the oven.
(JB sighs)
[Conan] It's hot.
(sighs) Right there.
[Conan] And what's happening is, is you--
[JB] Simmer down.
You are floating--
(hums) No, no, no, no, no, no, no--
No, no, you, you're
floating, I'm not floating.
I, I'm, you're floating.
Are you the pie?
[JB] You, you gotta, no.
(Sona laughs)
[Conan] Who's the pie?
[JB] You gotta levitate.
[Sona] What is happening?
(Matt laughs)
[JB] No, I--
[Conan] Who's the pie?
Am I the pie?
I haven't seen the pie
yet, I haven't seen it yet.
Oh, oh, I see, I see.
I see the pie is just
there, it's getting me
[JB] It's gotta cool off.
[Conan] Miles, you gotta help me out.
This, this man is so wise that
I don't always understand.
[Miles] The pie is the knowledge
that's going
to be dropped and--
(JB laughs)
[JB] He don't get it.
He don't get it, Miles.
He don't get it.
[Conan] Okay.
I want to get it, I want to get it,
I'm tired of being so
uptight and so trapped
in my own mind, and my own, I don't know.
[JB] You know, that's, that's okay.
It's okay, it's okay.
So, so, so, okay,
I put out the pie.
The pie is the knowledge.
I'm ready to accept the knowledge.
The scent of the pie,
has gone underneath my nostril,
and now I'm floating
like a cartoon animal floats along a scent
towards the pie.
(JB hums)
And I'm undulating through the air.
[Conan] And I smell that,
that delicious peach,
that cinnamon.
[JB] Oh.
That rhubarb.
Now, your senses are wide open right now.
Yes.
[JB] They're wide open right now.
Now you're willing to
accept what Miles and I,
what we truly do to,
to channel and to break
through all your barriers
barriers, you have barriers up right now.
I do.
[JB] And so
that's something Miles and I,
to start chipping away at that bullshit.
See if I may be blunt.
[Conan] Yeah.
[Miles] It's also my job to tell people
legally, do not leave your windows open.
(Sona laughs)
Yes.
[Miles] Like I just
follow behind
and clarify what's metaphoric.
(Sona laughs)
[Conan] (hums) Yes. That--
[Miles] Because they don't--
it's a metaphoric window.
[Miles] want to be
responsible.
We do not, Miles is here to tell you,
and this is very smart Miles,
and very smart of you
JB, to have Miles here.
JB cannot be concerned
with small concerns like
public safety and, and
and you know, crime and theft.
He can't worry about that.
He's living on a higher astral plane.
Miles is here to say
it's a psychic window.
Yes.
[Conan] And the pie is knowledge.
Please don't leave your
real window open with a
real cooling pie
because that's--
No.
how most murders--
Don't put your pies outside anyways.
(Matt laughs)
[Miles] It's just going
to attract wildlife and--
[Conan] Yeah.
[Miles] It's just
not a good decision.
(Sona laughs)